lagos has descended into chaos
gunfire rang out shops were looted and a
prison was set ablaze in nigeria's
biggest city on thursday
prompting the president to call for calm
i therefore call on our youth to
discontinue
the street process and constructively
engage
government in finding solutions
your voice has been hard loud
and clear and we are responding
people are losing faith in their
security forces and the government
after 12 protesters were allegedly
killed earlier this week
peaceful protests against a police unit
known as sars
had been underway across the country
since earlier this month
with a unit accused of torturing and
killing citizens live from the answers
they are shooting
but tensions escalated on tuesday night
when security forces
fired into a crowd of protesters singing
the national anthem
according to amnesty international from
what we are seeing on the ground
clearly um the they did not respect
um international human rights law and
nigeria's constitution as well
in terms of protecting people's lives
and securing
people's safety
the incidents sparked condemnation from
the international community
and violent unrest within the country
mobs vandalized and burned police
stations courthouses
and tv stations while police fought back
but the nigerian military has denied
shooting at the protesters to our
neighbors in particular
and members of the international
community
many of whom have expressed concern
about the ongoing development in nigeria
we thank you
and as you all to seek to know
all the facts available before taking a
position
or rushing to judgment and making hasty
pronouncements the president said he was
pained by the loss of innocent lives
but did not directly acknowledge the
protest shootings
it's a rhetoric that may not be well
received by the nigerians who have been
calling for an end to corruption for
weeks
and with us now from lagos nigeria is
correspondent fred
muvini fred tell us we heard that
president buhari has called for calm
are his comments appeasing nigerians
not really some nigerians were saying
that this is
actually a defiant statement and uh
they see this as actually a warning
rather than
asking them you know to to to come on
the table and negotiate
but also he did actually mention that
people should
the youth should come forward and
negotiate but
we all know that there is no one who is
heading this protest so even
talking about negotiations is actually
almost impossible do we know more about
what really happened
earlier this week
yeah we know that for example
military officers opened fire and at
least
more than a dozen people
has been done in terms of addressing
that issue
and making sure that people actually are
hold accountable rather we have seen
the military saying that they were not
responsible they were not behind
anything like that
the protests they started over police
brutality the discontent however growing
much deeper
doesn't it
yes yes if you look at these are the
issues here in nigeria people talk about
unemployment rate which is very very
high
we also had a report that more than 70
percent households
in major states in this country had to
skip their meals
uh during kobe 19 even up to now
there are so many issues including bad
governance people are talking about
so it's not just about the police
brutality it's about
everything that this country is going
through at the
at this moment fred mubini thank you so
much